so before we get into what it was like
when you first
you know are getting out of china i
wanted to ask you
experiencing you said neighbors
disappeared
yes for no reason and recently recently
one of my junior high school student
used to be on weight check
he disappeared too all for my junior
school good friends in my hometown they
don't know where he is
when you so when you were younger did
you understand what it was to have
someone disappeared
no i just know the adults sometimes
whisper
i was a child i i lived in that
courtyard
until we were about 16 to move
to another better place but this a
family here
korea would never i was always curious
when the people were talking about
something
like comments on society the government
i would like to ask a question they
always say
shh quiet go go there sit there you
child don't say anything
i just heard two people just gone i
don't know what happened to them
not supposed to ask questions and
there's no trial no
saying nothing no notification don't
know what happened
did you ever realize as you got older
what was going on
now i know people disappear all the time
even when i was in law school i did not
know i also did not know
lots of people starting to death i i did
not know any of those
i just wanted to base it i was young i
just wanted to have some personal
freedom
i want to be left alone so i decided
i should come to a free country so i can
be left alone that's all i wanted
i did not know how ugly actually china's
society was
what was what was it like to learn of
the first amendment
when you were shown that pocket
constitution
freedom of speech speak and free to
assemble free you know what it's kind of
funny
they had all that in the chinese
constitution too
and a soviet but they never never exist
in reality
they but so why believe them so but the
most important
when he told me that the u.s actually
has a separation for powers
that was most shocking to me it's oh we
have a three branch of government
you get to vote lily as a citizen it's
like
really you know my first time i voted in
the united states
it was year of 2000. i was 36 years old
first time to vote in my entire life i
took this
right so seriously where lots of people
don't even vote
but they're running over anyway if you
don't vote like some people don't vote
but
you know you you if you think
i'm not political i don't need to vote i
don't need to choose my own
you know like rulers they don't leave
your law they have
interest in you where you are not
interested in politics
they want to control you dominate you
and
take away more of your private property
even you suffer ownership of your body
look at what's happening
last year and this year right so that's
what the communists do
so when i realized oh i could come to
this country
later become citizen vote choose who
represents
me that was huge deal of course this
religious freedom
we will shut down all religions during
mouse cultural revolution
my grandmother my mom were buddhists and
all of a sudden we could not go to
buddha's temple to see buddha bless me
anymore
because that was not pc you need to say
long never turn my mouth
don't say long you know buddha bless me
so
i i in order to become young pioneer red
card
i could not tell people we were
buddhists
that would be stupid that's black class
i think maybe the the most shocking
thing may have been the discovery of the
second amendment
yes what what were you thinking when you
discovered americans can just have guns
i could not even comprehend
that and i could not comprehend that
i just thought are you sure are you sure
because in china it's in nico you go to
straight to jail right i want to tell
you funny saying when i first came to
this country
i was afraid of guns i was free to touch
it
it's like a gun is going to jump on me
and kill me or something then my husband
i'm married to a texan right i went to
gun range
and he they showed me first time i went
to gun range i
scared them a lot because i just said oh
what is this
people say oh no no later you you never
pick up gun like that
that's not responsible you could kill
somebody you number one rule
you never point at the person right so i
said okay
so they showed me how to use it and how
to practice
this or that so i start to feel a little
bit comfortable
and and when i fire first shot it was
very scary it was
loud even though i had the ear plugs and
then kicked back
like oh it was horrible i was horrible i
said oh it's better i don't touch guns
so i was still afraid
guns but after i become citizen learned
about
my rights and especially that the
pm square massacre happened
when you say citizens and the students
peaceful protesters were
slaughtered and i start to really
appreciate a second amendment you could
bake the tankers soldier to stop please
don't kill our student there are other
brightest best
like the beijing citizens did
so then xiaoping had to get those troops
from outside of beijing
because beijing soldiers could not do it
because they know they know oh they're
just peaceful protesters
they just won't have a dialogue with the
party officials
they were not talking about virtual
government at all so then xiaomi went
area to get the troops coming they're
all indoctrinated
we have a country revolutionary in the
beijing
go to crush them they knew the power of
college students they used the the young
ideological college students in the
first place
so naturally they understood that these
these people would bring about change
yes they stopped them so so if you're
not in line
you're labeled to be county
revolutionaries very sad
since 1989 the case is sealed
those students are counted revolutionary
according to china's law
so their moms dads were waiting for
years trying to get the case overturned
even just get a little bit better name
for their children who died that day
they couldn't do it it's a banned word
on the internet you cannot even search
tiananmen square music did you know
about gentlemen square massacre when you
were living in china
oh i was here in 1988 okay so i watched
the whole thing i was so sad
and i had a friend who worked for xinhua
news agency in beijing
they were there for entire six weeks
peaceful protests period just feels
excited
and they were just hoping of no
no no crackdown no no we just want to
have a dialogue we're not a country
religion we're not violent criminals
and so that night
they heard the gunshots one girl came
back to office
xinhua news agency the propaganda arm of
a chinese communist party
young college graduates that night all
cried
they lost hope my friends i don't know
where they are today
gang you think the state took them
some disappeared someone to jail i think
this guy who worked for xinhua news
against i think
he left country i don't know where he's
today
maybe australia i don't know he should
find me if he knew
i'm in america but i don't know where
they are he even told me
i'm not gonna have children i'm not
gonna get married maybe that's
the you know least thing i can do
so-called
contribute to my motherland i'm gonna be
gone
i'm not gonna have kids in this country
so most educated people are gone
you know i could not imagine wanting to
leave
america i i understand though actually i
took that back
you know growing up in the united states
and then working for companies where
i've traveled all over the world
i've seen how amazing america is because
you take it for granted
not being here or you take it for
granted being here i mean when i started
traveling around covering conflict and
crisis in other countries and then
seeing what the rules and the laws were
i was in thailand for instance you
couldn't even
paraphrase disparagement of the royal
family it's les might just stay it's
it's a crime even as a journalist to say
if let's say you know ian disparaged the
crown
i could not as a reporter say ian
crosslin made a comment disparaging the
crown
that itself was a crime and so i
remember having conversations with
foreign journalists
and one accidentally and referenced
someone insulted the king
and then panicked and started looking
around making sure because even as a
foreigner you can get in trouble
yes then i come back to america and i'm
going through the security line and i
see the the
the border cbp and they're looking like
yeah yeah yeah and i'm like i see the
american flag and i'm like wow
i know different huh i can say screw off
to the president all day and night and
laugh
and i can say it into the face of these
federal these federal agents these
officers
and they'd look at me like a weirdo and
i'd be like hey i'm just saying i love
america
i didn't say that obviously i'm saying
like you can
you and and it's it's crazy now with
what we're seeing with all this critical
race theory stuff
now i understand when when i hear these
stories about
cuba venezuela china the soviet union
that if these things do keep happening
here in the united states and they do
get as crazy as
they get crazier than they are then i
would understand you know why someone
would flee their country and that's
scary to me because
america is the last best hope i guess
i mean there's a lot of countries in the
world some of them are pretty good
uruguay is pretty chill
but america is is something unique with
that constitution that bill of rights
and if we don't defend it and we lose it
then
what what do we have where do we go
that's why i properly
come out and i found it with another
vietnamese american
uh new hampshire asian american
coalition
our first rally was about
unstopped critical race theory
indoctrination
we had 250 people showed up and
we had about 12 people on this stage
when we end the event holding
signs all men are critical
in their own native language japanese
thai chinese and you know
all kind of languages to say you know
what people even don't know what we're
saying
we just hold the signs and say this one
short sentence
until the last guy and the american guy
and and he's black and he holds the sign
said beautifully like all men are
critical
then we play the song the charts called
the american the beautiful
it was a very positive unifying moment
all those immigrants come from all over
the world
think america is exceptional country
the only country you can come
to achieve american dream i get
emotional when i think about that
like american dream where can you
achieve american dream
and i was just so touched by watching
them
oh my god it's like we defend america
america is not systemic racist country
otherwise why would the world want to
come
you know sorry about that it's a good
emotion
i agree i grew up here i grew up in
chicago
i grew up being told a lot of things by
leftists anarchists you know we didn't
have critical race theory back then but
we certainly had class theory
and so when i was younger i heard all
about you know
the one percent the rich and i have i
still have some some um
libertarian i consider myself to be left
libertarian i think libertarian comes
first in that
you can't force people to do things you
have to come to agreements and find
cooperation and negotiate there has to
be
mutual agreements and it really was
until uh
i started traveling the world and seeing
what other countries are like
then i start to realize man we really do
have something special here
i think america has it has its share of
bad history what country doesn't the
history of the world is fairly bad but
we've certainly made something special
and i think you hit the nail on the head
if it really was so awful and racist why
would everyone want to come here
well that's why i feel like uh you know
i learned about little slavery history
you know
no country is ever perfect and
we all have our issues we need to deal
with that's why it's so
important for all these citizens with
diversity
ideas minds thoughts skills to come
together
have conversations how are we going to
solve
our problems we face how we're going to
help our
communities our families but that's what
america is about we all are multi-part
immigrants from somewhere many years ago
how how could we condemn each other
how could we call it if you were born
white
you're racist your ancestors were racist
but i i come here i'm supposed to be
victim
oppressed as a chinese immigrant i came
here with nothing
nothing a hundred dollars borrowed
and i owe my professor sponsor twelve
hundred dollars in debt
i could not even speak english i was
about 24 years old
i walk away from a country my family
friends
and in a foreign land and american
people open their
arms to welcome me to offer me their
homes
free items kitchenware blankets clothing
because i was poor graduate student
and i lived in austin texas a
traditionally very wide neighborhood
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at 8
pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time